for the most part the way congress works
and has worked for many years now
is the speaker of the house has to let
it go through if the speaker says no
it's not moving um the speaker has
amassed
a tremendous amount of power this
probably started in the gingrich days
this was before my time of course
um and has continued and has has gotten
with successive speakers has gotten
worse for example
during my time in congress john boehner
a man i tried to oust from congress
i tried to oust him from the speakership
i didn't want him a speaker anymore
because i thought he was so bad
he actually ran a more open congress
than paul ryan
or nancy pelosi and that's hard to
believe
like if i could go back in time and say
to um you know past
justin amash hey this is actually as
good as it gets right now
i would have probably changed my
approach to it and said hey i guess we
we're going to stick with john boehner
for now but i tried to oust him because
i thought he was so bad i mean this is a
guy who one time called me a terrorist
and i still um you know
think he was probably the best speaker
we've had overall because he was he
cared about
uh opening up the process relative to
his successors
and it wasn't a super open process but
at least
we could offer amendments on the house
floor from time to time
and we don't have any of that now
so why do these bills get presented
without the opportunity for amendment it
is that
it's because it sounds like that's a big
part of the problem is that well hey
it's take it or leave it and then you're
like well i guess
like if i can't change it i'm gonna have
to say no to this thing
um when did that become the norm
so um until about 2016 may 2016 which is
uh while paul paul ryan was speaker
it was uh the tradition of the house
that
uh particularly on particularly on
appropriations bills so these are the
spending bills
you had something called an open process
where
any member of the house could come to
the house floor during the reading of
the bill
and offer an amendment and as long as
the amendment was germaine to the bill
that member would get a vote on that
amendment so we would have
votes on all sorts of things especially
like i said on appropriations bills
and um that that was the tradition of
the house for
uh you know over 200 years and then
along comes paul ryan and he says
you know the democrats are trying to put
in these poison pill amendments
they are offering amendments that are
causing
our members to have really tough votes
and
we don't want to have these tough votes
so what he told the republican
conference because i was there at the
when he announced this he said look
we're going to shut down the open
process
you guys can bring your amendments and
present them to the rules committee
and i will allow a lot of amendments to
go through
and be voted on the floor but i will be
able to weed out the
the um as he called them you know the
the dangerous or poison pill
democratic amendments we can weed those
out and
republicans were sitting there in the
room and they're like yes yes let's do
this
and i objected i said this is crazy
and first of all he's telling you he's
gonna just weed out these
um you know poison pill amendments he's
gonna weed out all sorts of amendments
once
once this process starts and what's the
end game
so what happens when the democrats are
in charge then they're like you know
ending
republican amendments this is a
dangerous game to play
and we shouldn't be doing this we should
have an open process we are
a body um where we're supposed to
discover the outcomes
through the legislative process but you
know i lost that argument
and republicans went forward with that
they shut down the amendment process
and paul ryan became the first speaker
in the history of our country to have a
whole term
where we had no open amendments in other
words there was never
a piece of legislation during his whole
term that he was speaker the ful
the the full term he served as speaker
where we were allowed to go to the floor
and offer an amendment
and nancy pelosi has carried that on
during her tenure as speaker
she has not allowed a single open
process
um during her entire tenure as speaker
during this recent tenure i
i can't speak for for before she must
have allowed it before
but recently she's followed the
precedent set by paul ryan
and that's really bad for the american
people
it's really really bad um i mean we
could talk about this for a long time
but
it affects everything it affects
executive power for example
i'll give you um just
just uh to flesh that out a little bit
if the president of the united states
knows that he only has to negotiate with
a couple people
it makes his job a lot easier he can get
what he wants
a lot more easily than if he has to
negotiate with the entire
congress so you've just given the
president
a tremendous amount of leverage by
closing down the process
that the uh framers of the constitution
never intended the president to have
and he only has to negotiate with nancy
pelosi and mitch mcconnell essentially
right there's only two people he has to
get it through because they run the
whole show
nobody else has any say now
people say to me when i say let's open
up the process let's
let's allow amendments oh this will take
forever justin this will
you'll slow everything down well first
of all we
we spend a lot of time on things we
don't need to be spending time on in
congress
i mean there's like a lot of stuff that
what
i just want to stop here for a second
justin and and just joke that it's like
oh because congress is such this model
of legislative efficiency right now
that if you were to allow amendments
that you'd be interfering with this
well-oiled machine that's just humming
along
right like anyone
anyone looking at it right now knows
that congress is not working efficiently
under this model
this model of mnuchin negotiates with
pelosi and mcconnell
is not efficient it's taken months look
at the the coveted relief stuff the leaf
bill
yes yeah it's taken months and months
to get anything and then they just they
negotiate for a couple weeks then the
president says something on twitter and
then they're like oh we're
we're stop we're going to stop
negotiating now and then he says no no i
changed my mind and they start again
this has been going on um for months for
months now
and if you just put legislation on the
house floor
and allow us all to participate every
single member
if justin amash has an idea let me offer
it
for people who say that it'll slow down
the process to offer amendments it won't
slow down the process
it will speed up the process and you
know what else you know what else
happens
every member of congress then feels like
they
participated in the process and so it
brings them on board and brings their
constituents on board with whatever the
final package is
because now you can say to your
constituents
i offered an idea that you guys really
wanted my constituents wanted this thing
i went on the house floor and i offered
it as an amendment but it didn't pass it
failed
so this is the product that is the
compromise
of the house of representatives and a
lot of members will then say well
this is the best we can do and this is
something that i'd be willing to vote
for
there are other members who say no i'm
not willing to vote for it and that's
okay too
the but the the fact is we went through
a process
and we got something that uh in a much
better way
reflects the will of the american people
and reflects the representatives
of the people they're using their
judgment on behalf of the people
why do you think more has not been made
of the fact that the legislative process
now uh shuts down the ability to amend
um because at this point it's been in
effect since 2016.
we can see some of the negative effects
people are very
upset about how uh unresponsive congress
has been
to a crisis after crisis at this point
and covid relief is
the crisis of the moment uh i have not
heard that much in the press
uh beating up um either paul ryan or
nancy pelosi for
shutting down amendments and it seems
like a fundamental problem would you
agree first of all with the sense that
this is
somewhat underreported oh it's it's way
underreported and i've i've complained
to reporters about it i've said this is
like
this is the big story because when i go
to town halls and i talk to my
constituents
and um and obviously we haven't been
doing in person town halls with the
covet situation but
uh back in the day they would say to me
justin um you know the process is all
fine and all like it's it's nice that
there's some procedural problems but we
care about the substance we need to get
this
this bill and i say to them you can't
get that bill that you want you can't
get that idea that you want without an
open process there's no way for a member
of congress
to bring that to the floor to offer it
so there's this expectation
that i as a member of congress can go
and just
offer things and have votes on them and
that's just not true
um i can't even tweak bills so let alone
i mean forget the idea of offering my
own bill
i can't even amend bills so
that is a real problem and it's under
reported i think because it's just not a
sexy topic
like really because this strikes me as
very very you know
in the sense that it's very impactful i
mean well you you and i
yeah you know i think this is like in
our
uh wheelhouse where you know i'm to me
i'm like a procedure person this is sort
of how i think i think about process
um because if you control the process
that has a big impact on the outcome so
the way the the
leadership teams are controlling the
process now in both the house and senate
that
impacts the outcome very directly i i
would hope that we can all agree
on following a process that allows
everyone to participate
so that the libertarian can offer ideas
on the house floor
the progressive can offer ideas on the
house floor the conservative can offer
ideas on the house floor
we want to bring all of these viewpoints
to this magnificent body
that was created in our country this
magnificent
body to uh to legislate on behalf of the
american people we want to bring
all of these viewpoints there and work
to persuade each other
but i can't do that until we fix the
procedural
process stuff so my focus
my focus really has been on that thank
you for listening in i hope you enjoyed
this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you